citizens of the reject Nation it is John
and it is Tara Erickson and we are back for
some nautical nonsense today as we dive into
DreamWorks animations classic motion picture
Shark Tale starring William Smith and Martin
Scorsese as I remember from the trailer many
many many many many years ago but hey before
we hop into that Tara how you doing I'm good
I just did a little scuba thing for you guys in
case anyone was like I don't know what she was
doing was she dying I wasn't this is a it was
a scuba thing doing the scoobs I like it leave
a like for Tara's scuba thing also remember
to subscribe to the channel and when you do
ring that Bell [Music] that's right and don't
forget to subscribe to Tara Erickson follow
her on social media follow La eat some drinks for
tips and tricks about how to dine and wine in Los
Angeles and hey before we hop into this if you
want to get the full experience see everything
that doesn't make these reaction highlights
come on over to patreon.com the real rejects
you can sync up with your own copy enjoy all of
Shark Tale alongside Tara and I and now without
further ad yeah so let's get nautical are you
ready yeah yeah yeah I'm ready shark it up
foreign [Applause]
[Music]
Works logo used to look like oh my God it
is DreamWorks old school I like it yeah
whoa oh at least the worm is tied to the hook
poor little wormy instead of gored through it
worms are friends not food
oh poor guy
hi I'm Lenny I'm gonna get you out of here Jiffy
you just keep holding your breath a little wormy
I'm coming Frankie I'll move it come on Pop's
waiting here we go gotcha yay I was just uh
picking you some flowers hey Mom said it's
not okay to hit okay we're in the gills
such pretty underwater flowers yeah
Renee Zellweger is in this holy chunk
and Jack Black look at this that was
Jack Black Angelina Jolie is in
this y'all come on now and Marty
so we're about to get some Cinder says the
sharks are gone I repeat the sharks are gone
damn what is this Brian Square gup
like their cheeky advertisements
Martha sturgeon's flowers okay starfish tours
of course I've been on a star tour once [Music]
big fan of seal the actual seal eels eels eels
prawn shop nice yes [Music] it's fake I
worked eight years on that no how'd you
produce a fake Pearl there's so many questions
about the physics here I bet you that Sushi's
so good so fresh hasn't even left the water
yet wait a minute is that a fish serving sushi
is there no hero Among Us who can stop this shark
Menace hi I'm Oscar you might think you know but
you have no idea whoa okay CD DVD PlayStation
hookup and an eight-track player for those days
when you're feeling just a little old school uh
do you have an actual vinyl though I'm pretty sure
not even a great Penthouse can I be your financial
advisor well that's a good crazy Joe 's this is by
far my favorite character oh shouldn't you kids
be in school shouldn't you be at work oh right
back at me huh little smart mouth look I'm on my
way y'all stay out of trouble all right hey and
clean that stuff up yeah before you caused some
foreshadowing that's pretty good artwork there
God they can graffiti on the whales that's
cool yeah I'd like to see that in real life
as long as it doesn't hurt the whales I'd be
like oh what a pretty little whale [Music]
oh my okay going in for a wash
[Applause]
that's great okay so if you're an eel
you have multiple forms of employment
not just stripping yeah I'm already punched
in Angie good morning can I help you please
oh may I suggest a barnacle peel removes
lines and salt damage I love him you're
gonna get me fired nah that can't happen
because then I would have absolutely no
reason to come to work you're like my
best friend oh that's so sweet oh dang
oh no not the Titanic oh no oh God PTSD yeah
I've lived my life for my sons raising them
and protecting them you're the best he's the
best am I right Am I Wrong am I right it's
all been to prepare oh my God this guy for the
day they run the reef well today is that day
fix the record
wrong track hey boss what compilation album is
that yeah that they can move on to the next track
and it's classic all I'm saying is the kid ain't
exactly no killer my Lenny is a killer look at him
kill him with kindness and charm you are out what
you're fired no fire Martin Scorsese there
is a lot of Titanic Easter eggs in this yeah
she's gonna blow [Music]
grab him
save him from the uvula quadrant
I could look like you y'all funny
well see if you laughing yes thanks
[Music]
look I've been going over my markers you're into
me for five grand oh I have to start paying down
legal protection so everything you owe me you owe
him the food chain you see on top there's John
Lena there's me and there's regular fish oh that's
me no you're at the bottom there's Carl there's
there's whale poo and then there's you how'd you
get separated from the rest of the fish bring my 5
000 clams to the racetrack tomorrow or
else or else what the boys will explain
laughs but Pleasant 5 000 clams and they
must be actual clams right because I'm
I'm a little fish in a big pond a really big
pond the ocean the ocean yeah the biggest pond
I want some of that Mrs Sanchez all right there
you go live your best life the top of the reef
where does some bodies live I want to be
here where the somebody's are what's wrong
with down here remember my dad he worked at
the wash his whole life oh yeah all right he
was the number one tongue scrubber great
hair though Dad yeah dude killing it Earl
dude why are kids so mean your pops had Pride man
nobody loves a nobody that's not true I want to be
a somebody don't think you're nobody's nothing
after all wait here if she gives him like her
whole savings I might be a little upset yeah
how many clams you got in storage what's this
a pink pearl my grandmother gave it to me oh
from a tiny grain of sand I grew into something
beautiful Dreams Can Begin small too no uh-uh no
I couldn't at all it'll get you the money you need
from Mr Sykes better not mess this up buddy she
loves you man what's that understand we've been
over this a thousand times I would love to dine
at this restaurant the vibe here is Tip Top I bet
you the steak is very good Pacific ocean eats
and drinks coming soon your brother Frankie
here he's a killer throw pop he's beautiful he
does what he's supposed to do wipe your face
you was for both ears I need to
know that you can handle that I
need to know that you're cold-blooded
right here in front of me now eat this
I'm on a diet and I read an article about
these shrimps they're not good for you I
tell you you know how many calories are in
one of those shrimps a lot no my sister had a
Pig oh no I'm not asking anymore I'm telling you
eat it the shrimp please oh god oh no [Music]
one's looking go get out of here you're
free now everyone's looking good you're
a good person person huh you're gonna learn how
to be a shark whether you like it or not oh poor
Lenny but he doesn't want to be a shark not that
kind of shark carrying a big old envelope full
of money give it to Mr oh no oh my god oh Jesus
oh my goodness the race is rigged we can't loads
well what's the horse's name oh no Lucky Dog you
dare gamble it of course he's gonna gamble it what
Dreams Can Begin small small just just had to bet
it all no dude how much you got is that is that
only five thousand dollars bet whatever is extra 5
000 unlucky day to win no oh my goodness no Oscar
the millionaire oh this is terrible I'm stressed
oh my God is that Angelina Jolie I bet it is oh
it must be it has to be gotta be Jolie it's Gotta
Be You Got a Name Well mine's Lola of course it is
my name is Oscars
he escort you to my box your box you can't
even afford the gum under the seats he just
laid five grand on lucky day I think he can afford
anything he wants ugh my five grand no it wasn't
enough give me that sucks take the
ticket get a refund then that's all
I'll be over I'm really super
friend okay wrong you're cute
oh dang Lola she's harsh yeah man
she's laid the subtext out [Music]
the long shot Lucky Day the one they bet on
gonna move on it come on well come
on okay catch up catch up catch up
round the curve real fast maybe maybe it has
like Nitro in his blood yeah hit the knots
yeah he's got that not system let's go let's go
yeah yeah yeah get it get it get it get it get it
oh oh no no come on no no no no no
come on buddy ah come on oh my goodness
Something's Gonna go wrong
right like what what is it um
[Music] that is painful he punched
himself in the faith was his own tail
this is terrible all righty Bernie I
want you to find the deepest darkest home
[Music]
oh sorry kid it's nothing
personal it's just business
trunk shot yep love it this is referencing
all the kids favorite movies why is it
that meloxicam sting out of people but
they have no effect on me or you hey
good old practical jokes it's the core of
any good friendship you see TV dinner Eye
of the Tiger Frankie I do this what if I can't
do this then don't bother coming home good point
good point guys guys don't leave me
alone come on there could be sharks
out here I feel like this is gonna be the
start of a beautiful friendship [Music]
do me a favor don't chew
me I don't I'm not for that
look I'm just pretending so you can get
away and when I turn around you take off
tastes just like chicken nice oh no damn it
dude that's it I've had it up to here [Music]
oh snap oh no I hate it stronger so
sad can they really bite through a
chain like that I'm so cold that's
just because we're cold-blooded wow
oh no oh boy is he really
dying yeah I guess so oh no
ah it's okay jabels
Oscar did you kill that shark bet your gills
I did yeah yeah yeah exactly exactly how I
look that's how it is big old shark map
7 500 feet long yeah right is this like a
sing Talk any shock try to mess around
in Oscar town it's going down bars and
you are I'm his manager uh Sykes with a
Y and I'm his financial advice yes yes
just let him do it he's my favorite yes he's
got puppets I'll watch that whole movie right
there so what exactly are we talking about here
50 50. you happy no you happy no deal [Laughter]
any shark tries to bother this Reef good
luck with that Oscar oh man it's gonna
be open season in a hot second I got the
Titanic life preserver for his memorial
thank you for your kind
thoughts Giuseppe very kind
it's for maturity it might be found safe and sound
too don't worry boys I said some things to him oh
what's just what happened how they got some
news about the guy who took out Frankie
to the ground ah baby oh my goodness wow lots of
publicity bad publicity I'd be like um how about
we don't tell anyone so I don't have to fight
off sharks because I haven't fought off any yeah
[Music]
to the penthouse my dude in a penthouse now
with a like a whole room size lava lamp nice
Angelina Jolie is gonna show up and there's
gonna be drama I feel it well what does every
bachelor pad need a lava lamp how did you know
I love lava lamps you know what I'm gonna put it
right because she's your best friend Donald oh
no oh oh take it back I'm not impressed by the
room size lava lamp anymore just sorry that it
took so long oh that's okay bam my grandmother's
Pearl oh geez I don't forget anything and
I never forget who my friends are oh hi
I'm not interrupting something
yes you are get out of here Lola
on the edge of the reef that's the great white
time to show your skills which are lacking
oh where they oh that was close
super close Benjamin don't panic
quiet yo what is with you man huh you
could be anywhere the shark slayer
there's no shark slayer out here yes
there is so they obviously haven't seen
the magazines in shark World apparently not
it's not safe to be out here at night it is
yeah
sometimes I'll be coughing for nothing
Oscar the shark slayer that's what people
be saying you mean you yeah yeah when
the anchor oh you're a liar [Music]
Orca police of course they would be
can you get that shark oh you have no
idea Joe that's great well Gotta Go My show's on
we're safe for now that's good oh that's heaven oh
so comfy buggly wobbly I love you man oh Bromance
in the event that possibly you know you get
hungry don't worry I'm not gonna eat anyone
I'm different from the other sharks Define
different you'll laugh yeah I'm a vegetarian
oh come on man I'm so tired of keeping it all a
secret and my dad he'll never accept me for who
I am what's wrong with me oh how does he get his
vegetables that's what I'm wondering yeah if you
want to blame anybody blame me you know because
if I hadn't been out there in the first place
none of this would have happened yeah pop knew
that he'd ice you for sure was he The Godfather
or something yeah yeah he is [Music] thanks the
deal is up the shark I killed was Don Lino's son
I know ain't it great not if he finds out huh I've
got him on the phone right now that's right Leno
I got the shark slayer right here in front of me
oh boy this is what we call bad management yeah
he's right here shut up you don't come me shut
up I tell you shut up what hello how you doing
let me have a pie with everything on it yeah two
of these meatballs mushrooms anchovies get off
the line get off the phone my guys are coming
for you shock Slayer they're gonna tear you
Finn from fin yes I love how the fish are more
advanced and have cell phones and sharks still
have landlines I know come on maybe I can help
oh hey hello hello how are you doing here you
just be popping up sometimes places ah oh my God
just one thing on top of the other we actually I
was thinking about retiring you don't want to
do that oh my Lola is intense she has glitter
in her hair is she working yeah what does she
want she's like a double agent hello Oscar gee
what are you doing here what Oscar did you forget
something your big shark friend you're a shark
what were you thinking bringing him in here
ever slayed the shark who am I
to tell him that they're wrong
don't take it personally
come on I lied to everybody
yeah oh geez sharks are coming to get me
and they should what's the plan all right
this is what we're gonna do Oscar
you tell the truth and you go home
I don't think Oscar can do that we're gonna
paint you up all bloody right and you gonna
swim out and meet the Sharks before they get
here and you will say stop that shocks that's
crazy man he beat me senseless he's a stone cold
killer man you need to slay a shark and I need
to disappear here's what we're gonna do oh now
you're thinking like a family a planning suits
[Applause]
of course you can start a
new life now give me a growl
[Music] whoa that was pretty good Lenny oh
no it's Pinocchio of course it's me references
I think I'm gonna puke
Maximus
how we supposed to find the Sharks player ouch
[Applause]
just like we practiced flying fish
all right a little help here buddy boy
thank you
wowie it's like Sea World but with fish
and a shark instead of an orca and a human
all right that's some good acting Lenny I feel
like he did pretty good there tell Don lame-o
that I don't never ever ever never want to
see another shark on this Reef again boom
I thought they were gonna be like yeah but there's
six of us let's just eat him yeah oh [Applause]
hey how's the Reef's most eligible bachelor
been snapped up I'm Katie Couric here live
Oh Katie current Katie Couric duh John is
just joining the party yes what did I miss
I saw your big finish on the news nice smooch
lover boy ixnay on the SK man that's private
it's private whoa somebody's in a bad mood come
on let me see this smile show me the smile baby
off what has gotten into you me bro how can you
not you really have I can't tell room do you think
do you even be with you in the Rich and Famous
sharks you guys please at least he treats me
like I'm somebody yeah but would she love you if
you were nobody nobody loved me when I was nobody
there we have it finally money and before the fact
you didn't see any of her love Doodles just go
because I'm tired of hearing how everything you
had in your life wasn't good enough including me
let's just realized the irony that Will
Smith is playing a character called Oscar
s see you're you made it to the top
kid and you're not happy not right
now there's a lesson to be learned here
Oscar no I don't think so I don't think
so I think he just needs to keep the lie
going you know hey shark slayer all your
friends are inside not all my friends you mean
that little bottom feeder from the whale Wash
about her forget about it rude she loves you
is that it it's not like you feel the same way
about her oh Oscar's heart grew three sizes
that time you know what I don't think this is
gonna work out wait good for you Oscar yeah oh my
God let me explain something to you whoa birthday
[Laughter] that's pretty funny sound effects
I gotta find Angie I mean I need to tell her
uh uh she gonna be gone she's gonna be gone
I just know it very very low considering all
good washes good one Ernie how many times do
I have to tell you it's gosh you get a whale
of a wash and the price oh my gosh all right
Sykes where's Angie you tell me whale Wash
you get a whale of a washer oh yeah ah file
cabinet top drawer there's a package get it
okay be there if you don't want to see
her sleeping with the fishes the dead ones
sure now nod your head if you understand let
me see you dodge your head like this now tell
me if you nodded your head I nodded this is all
my fault that's the classic move I've seen it a
thousand times they take the thing you love how'd
you missed all the Doodles man we gotta save it
whoa whoa whoa look I want to save Angie too but
I can't just Waltz in there and say hi pop I'm a
dolphin Lenny uh this is a joke right this is a
joke because you know I told Lino shut up Lino
shut up uh tell me that's a lot of money tell me
your real shock Slayer please I'm sorry Sykes ugh
and my man Sykes has just begged me not
to mortalize all y'all up in fertilize
and that depends on the individual behavior of all
the individuals in here individually I'm not done
the boss and if you thought a guy like me can't
get to a guy like you you're thought wrong oh good
I barely even know that girl what's your name Miss
gonna have to tell the truth he's bluffing knew it
knew it she's a villain there's only
one thing I like better than money
Revenge your shock sland days are over [Laughter]
that's what I sound like when I'm
having a mental breakdown yep you
you got nothing Sebastian take her out
dance dancing oh boy new rules nobody
makes a move without my okay from now
on everything flows through me and you
don't say okay without my okay okay oh
you just made it back and take a good look
Lino he's gonna barf her out old school Oscar
[Applause]
are you okay no I am not okay I couldn't
take it Lenny [Music] you're alive oh [Music]
hey boss it's Lenny he was wearing
a disguise so we wouldn't recognize
are you kidding me are you out of your
mind do you have any idea how this looks
this is just a bit down I've ever been to it's
not his fault this is between you and me you
took Frankie away then you turned Lenny into
a dolphin I'm gonna get you oh boy be alive
he's not the Slayer anymore look
who's stuck in the porthole [Music]
kids love Scarface
use it use your car wash skills
no no not Ange game's over
oh uh-oh
no let's finish the shots land
oh we're about to oh what do you
got up your sleeve nerfan just
popped our bubble yet yeah okay
dude but he's gonna feel so pampered
after this so good nice and shiny
thank you for coming to whale watch man
somebody needs to get me out of the bubble today
tell the world tell the truth
oh there we go it was an anchor that killed
Frankie that was true why did you run away
because you always wanted me to be like Frankie
so your son likes kelp he likes to dress like
a dolphin so what everybody loves him just
the way he is yeah I didn't know what I had
until I lost it get me out of this so I can hug
my kids oh I love you son no matter what you eat
or how you dress that's so sweet I didn't need the
top of the reef everything I wanted right there in
front of me well what about being a somebody
I'm nobody without you no you know romantic
come here you big dumb dummy head yeah
yeah you're the best henchman a guy ever had
come on Groupon sorry man sorry come Sykes try
again man don't forget come on don't forget
at the moment we cool right I mean like the
reef is safe we don't walk the streets you know
yeah open up the city to the Sharks we're cool
oh that's nice Oscar you've lost everything
you've lied so hard to achieve what's next for
you get my job back Mr manager hey I just got
to put to finish touch on my new desk [Music]
and and Oscar's whale Wash is now open
for business oh they teamed up okay oh
I thought it was gonna be whale and shark wash it
should be it should be right come on now [Music]
sorry Pop and I are late but we brought some new
customers yay yeah there we go good did they get
free washes then no no snap it snap it you're
not snapping it I'm snapping it I'm snapping
it's okay a lot of great whites can't do it yo yo
what's up what's up with what yo yo yo yo yo yo yo
huh Cinema
hell yeah I want some oh hey
oh yeah
it's not a DreamWorks from this era without
a dance number and some hip-hop references
they know how to cheerlead
hey
not bad she had a very delicate voice performance
Renee Zellweger really you thought that I
I well besides Angelina but I was like oh
that's so Renee like with her oh sure but
there's something about just like the quality
of it it was very sort of like close to the mic
delicate I don't know okay yeah I get what
you mean okay oh Sopranos cred in there it
was actually Katie Couric that's fun inside
Christina Aguilera singing it must be right
oh I wonder because I feel like they did a lot of
stuff with like you know musical guests back then
comes full circle
not bad all right well we did it what'd you think
oh Rob Letterman I think he directed Goosebumps
down the line oh okay I could be wrong about that
what'd you think Tara I mean I liked it I did I'm
not like oh wow I love this movie I'm like but
yeah I liked it in the end the end was fun yeah
I like the end this was one of those movies that
certainly when it came out I might have rolled my
eyes because because I don't know like there is
a moment in time and it still happens now but I
feel like it was especially prevalent where
you would have on the more DreamWorks end of
the spectrum and other Studios but I feel like
they were especially kind of known for having
these animated movies that would get these like
really stacked voice casts and yeah it would be
like okay we're gonna have like a lot of hip
cool hip-hop references and we're gonna like
do needle drops and we're gonna reference like
movies for adults and stuff and that can you
know like that can read as kind of corny yeah but
yeah know I mean with the room oh oh oh post cred
Oscar listen baby I know I was a bad girl you'd
have to be crazy not to take me back did someone
say crazy oh yeah oh okay weird yeah all right
all right yes that was odd but okay yes yeah
um what were you yeah yeah like this does come
from a period of time where I feel like you
know yeah you have these more sort of like we're
trying to be hip kind of movies but I mean this
was perfectly sweet and enjoyable and it was
fun and certainly I mean with the removal of
time I'm a little more open to the idea that like
a kid can easily enjoy this despite the fact that
there are lots of things here that are that are
in their head right yeah with all the references
kids aren't gonna care about Robert De Niro
and Martin Scorsese and like all of the random
um you know Mafia movie references that come
with that right uh and the various you know
like there's Jaws over here and like kids I don't
think know who Katie Couric is right but uh yeah
like I thought that they did a fun job of of
using those things and not like dominating the
whole movie with them see because I was gonna
say they used them but I was like I don't know
that the story was great enough for me to be like
fully invested and also with those Easter eggs on
top to be like those are diamonds uh like I I
don't know there was maybe it's just like the
I don't know like the pacing for me maybe it was
just the beginning maybe I'm just tired you guys I
don't know I like the movie inner child there was
yeah yeah I'm not saying this is like the greatest
animated movie there was just something about
it that I was like oh why am I not like really
liking this right now even though it wasn't like
bad there were the the references which I thought
were fun but I don't know why I didn't find
it more fun and I'm assuming because maybe it
wasn't wrapped up in a story that I really was
like invested in and I don't know I don't know
why not yeah I mean you know as Story Goes it's a
pretty well-worn territory for this kind of thing
it's about appreciating what you have it's about
realizing that you can you know live your true
self and not have to kowtow to the expectations
of your family or society and yes you should be
honest and you should embrace the gifts that you
do have instead of selling out to get to the top
but that's all normal tropes right right yeah
I mean it's very well-worn territory for what
kind of movie this is and it doesn't necessarily
trans like the way it sets itself apart if it sets
itself apart it doesn't like let you it doesn't
like linger to where you think there might be a
bait and switch you kind of see it coming from
the beginning right yeah yeah certainly maybe
that's why yeah it's definitely like a predictable
movie yeah uh and it's got yeah a lot of tropes
of animation and tropes of movies that are aimed
at kids it's just wrapped in this package that's
trying to be a little more hip yeah it's trying
to be a little more like Cinema referential
um but for what it was like I had a lot more I I
had a much more enjoyable time than I expected to
when I first saw you know yeah first learned of
this and was like okay here we go like when he
told me we're watching Shark Tale I was like what
what is what is that what is it yeah no I mean
I remember seeing trailers uh a bunch growing up
and and yeah it's like it's been there throughout
my life but yeah and two I mean like it is fun to
hear the a voice cast like this at this moment in
time when so many of these guys were I mean Jack
Black I think is still like at the Pinnacle right
now in terms of like he's still super popular
and recognizable and successful and a lot of
these guys are too but I feel like yeah like this
was probably at a time where it was like that was
like dang it's insane yeah yeah and I feel like
they let Will Smith just kind of do his thing and
there were some yeah and like with that there's
some genuine genuinely great times where I was
like laughing out loud which I thought was very
very funny from Will Smith and then a couple other
ones where I was like that's very funny yeah and
also I miss like Will Smith's delivery yeah Primo
in in some of these like jokes in his delivery I
was like oh he's so funny well yeah it's like you
got Will Smith doing Will Smith and then you have
Jack Black doing more of a character and then you
have everybody else kind of doing doing something
in between yeah because certainly De Niro the
whole point was like come in and be De Niro I'm so
fascinated as to how Martin Score says he wound up
being like a main supporting character in this
like whose idea was that what made him agree to
that what maybe they were just like you show up
for one day and let us use your voice you read
these lines and you're done I guess maybe like
yeah and it's one of those worlds too where I
don't find the need necessarily to like poke holes
and everything it's one of those societies where
you're like there's a lot of clever and fun you
know little gags and twists on the fish version
of how Society works and like oh it's you know Gap
instead of our gup instead of Gap and things like
that yeah you know it's one of those Society uh
fictional societies where I think you don't you
shouldn't think too hard about it because a lot
of the things don't probably really work if you
think much about them but yeah except like it it
was this was made in 2004 right so that was one
thing I forgot to mention is that it's it's nice
to know there was a movie out there that existed
way before it's time to show people like it's okay
to be who you are because they're kind of saying
like if you want to cross dress or maybe be gay
or be different I know this is me reaching John
but I'm like at the very end of them going like I
accept you for who you are is nice yeah right for
2004 I think what what that's like a while ago
when it wasn't like a wild time for everyone to
like be who you want to be yeah when being who
you wanted to be still kind of more just meant
like hey if you have like an odd uh life path you
want to pursue like you know if do it but keep it
like you want to be an artist or something or you
want to open a hot dog whatever it is you know
like you can do it but but yeah I feel like there
is that beat at the end where they are like if my
son wants the dresses the dolphin you know like
it's just there and enough that at this moment
in time you are like that's kind of picked up
efficacy with age you know even though most
of the movie is basically just like I'm timid and
I'm not a carnivore so how do I still be accepted
by my Shark family like that little beat at the
end does make it a little bit more Rich of theme
even though the movie's not about that not that at
all you know but at least there's a little touch
of that at the end which I liked yeah yeah and
it's just one of those like Pleasant flourishes
like yeah this this wasn't uh uh like revelatory
necessarily but it did have like some flourishes
where I was like yeah okay that's pretty fun
that's uh I had a a a a a a a fun time more
than I was sitting here like you know rolling my
eyes or gagging on things you know and I feel like
it would be easy for a film like this to be more
cringe yeah oh yeah and I wasn't I didn't feel I
was I was having a good time I think I might also
just be very tired yeah yeah well no I mean I'm
not saying you have to love this movie I'm just
saying you know like this comes from that time
where I feel like especially the Trope and they
make fun of this nowadays of like why do animated
characters always gotta you know break dance and
they always gotta rap yeah um but even so like uh
in subtle ways I thought that kind of complemented
the movie because again given who the Will Smith
Oscar is who his dad is you're like okay this
guy's growing up in you know like a lower class
part of town and is dreaming of moving to the rich
part of town and that's probably a very common
thing people can relate to yeah and then you know
the way in which yeah you might lose yourself
along the way um but you know like the whole thing
with Lola very predictable yeah and and yeah like
the outcomes like the drama itself always lets you
know it pretty much exactly what the outcomes are
gonna be oh yeah but yeah I like the camaraderie
between Will Smith and Jack Black and I liked you
know the ultimate wrap-up made me feel good enough
you know yeah I mean it's like that lesson of like
you can shoot for the stars and everything but if
you're not being honest with yourself and truthful
then like whatever you gain in that process or
the Journey of getting to the top is not going
to be worth it yeah so we're like yeah we get that
and you can't really climb to the top without the
gratitude for what you have here yeah truth
but I like some of the settings I like their
uh Titan their their wrecked Titanic headquarters
and things like that and uh yeah yeah it's pretty
fun overall I I this was what I was hoping for in
the sense that I just want to have a good time you
know get a little bit of blast from the past yeah
and uh and I mean too for earlier animation like
we've certainly come leaps and bounds in terms of
textures and just you know yes how great and real
and vibrant everything looks but I still liked a
fair amount of the design choices here I thought
the world again had a nice little colorful
personality and uh and yeah you know it's a
cartoon certainly but uh it's got its moments
yeah it's not yeah it's not the kind of movie
that's gonna make you cry but I'm like you know
the emotional beats are at least they're they're
on point yeah like yeah this is something that I
I I was heartened because I was like okay I could
easily see how a kid could enjoy this whereas when
I first you know saw that trailer I was like who
is this for you know but uh yeah you know not bad
I think kids would like it yeah neat voice cast
some fun takes on different characters and things
like that you know so uh yeah Linda and uh one of
the or both I can't remember if it was one or both
but uh one of the jellies was Ziggy Marley really
oh snap yeah okay some fun additional voices all
right Cass I swear to you guys that was Christina
Aguilera singing at the end it was it was yeah
her and Missy Elliott were on that track I think
according to the uh credits so uh so good she's so
good I mean you can hear that voice from anywhere
oh yeah it's got the frequency you can hear it at
the bottom of the ocean um but yeah any any final
thoughts before we hit the road to Tara Erickson
no no except that I'm glad the whale Wash became
a whale and shark walk absolutely bringing people
together and keeping it clean Under the Sea yeah
man I like that well guys leave us your thoughts
on this classic DreamWorks animated motion
picture and uh we will catch you on the flippers
slipper side but before we do let's do a patreon
Gabriel listen dude I know you don't always want
the angel comparison however think of it this way
you if you lived under the sea uh-huh could be
Gabriel the angel fish Wow and think of it you
would have such lovely beautiful flowing uh
things and yeah like beautiful colorations
and stuff like that like if I could catch you
and then bring you home and and raise you in my
own aquarium so that we could be best buds and
Inseparable forever I think that's what I would
want Gabriel all right he just wants an angelfish
for himself I thought he was saying like you could
be the angelfish of the entire ocean which
would be like great job everybody knows you
also that you're famous like him but he's like
no I want to keep you all to myself which is
you know I'm just saying I I think I think you
could get a better deal Gabriel I'm saying if
you were the angel fish down there I'd say Gabriel
away from me I'd say release them into the wild
let him do his angel stuff for whoever all right
fine you know what Gabriel just go let's go good
there's plenty of other fish but there's
only one Gabriel and that's fine we had our
time together go Gabriel go he lets
you go out I don't want you anymore
Gabriel I'm throwing uh whatever you get
here's a mollusk shell the whole thing
video like when I leave he's like just go
leave fine I don't love you anyway him I
every time after we film go live your life yeah
but stay pledged that's the most important you
can go wherever you want as long as you stay
pledge so keep that going and you know keep those
clams rolling in rolling and uh we will catch
you next month love you buddy be well foreign